cómo
por favor
[Aplausos]
nos ha tocado un mundo muy difícil nos
ha tocado un mundo donde tenemos que ser
perfectos hoy en la mañana victoria
secret
anunció que por primera vez en su
historia y va a tener la primer modelo
plot site una modelo húngara que mide 1
75 de estatura y pesa 55 kilos es neto
esto es los 6
oigan pero pero así estamos en todo
tenemos que ser flacos y nos venden todo
tipo de cosas parece que sólo podemos
ser fitz después tenemos esta onda de
ser jóvenes a ver la mayoría de los que
están aquí es fácil tienen 20 años y
sienten que cumplir 30 falta mucho la
realidad es que los que tenemos más de
30 50 y algo
pareciera que estamos arrumbados y que
ya no funcionamos y entonces todo el
mundo triste del botox de pastillas de
cosas vayan los 20 los 40 son los nuevos
20 oigan esto es muy raro y entonces lo
que tenemos estos modelos de belleza
perfecta
eso es sólo es el principio de la expert
esto es solo es el inicio de lo que
buscamos como humanidad de perfección de
dónde sale todo esto que a quién se le
ocurrió que hiciéramos todo esto y luego
viene por último una serie de películas
que nos presentan modelos increíbles por
ejemplo bradley cooper es un tipo que no
da pie con bola es un loser y un día se
toma una pastilla y se vuelve perfecto
guapo inteligente escritor capaz hace
ejercicio se mueve
oigan yo tengo alumnos que me dicen
dónde puedo comprar esas pastillas
quieres saber qué es lo peor si las
venden a ver no está exactamente pero si
existe en claro y entonces que no se
está diciendo lo que nos rodea qué es lo
que está pasando no se está hablando de
transhumanismo fíjense qué fuerte es una
corriente cultural es una corriente
filosófica una corriente científica que
se ha vendido de maravilla que hemos
comprado hasta el tuétano y que todos
decimos si quiere unos tenis que te los
pongas y por ir al refrigerador infla
qué es
todos queremos una pastilla que te la
tomes las 700 hojas y ya te lo sepas
oigan pero aquí yo tendría una pregunta
eso es lo humano la realidad es que
todos queremos ser mejores todos
quisiéramos ser fit y ejercicio todos
quisiéramos ser bellos pero ver según
bien hay una serie de ideólogos gente
muy talentosa que si a mí me preguntan
yo los invitaría perfectamente cerámicas
son sobre todo un filósofo sueco nick
bostróm que está en oxford university un
filósofo viotti sistemas que filósofo
australiano que también está en oxford y
un señor que se ve muy raro
aubrey de grey que oigan es un tipo muy
talentoso que está en california y
entonces bueno que están planteando o
que plantea toda esta corriente de
pensamiento
está planteando que el hombre es el
único animal que no puede evolucionar
como los demás que solo podemos
evolucionar
por medio de la razón que a ver tiene
una parte de razón la razón es nuestro
elemento y dicen y el siguiente paso
evolutivo lo daremos por medio de la
razón con ayuda de la tecnología para
quedarnos con lo que nos interesa de la
vida humana y eliminar lo que no nos
gusta qué es lo que no nos gusta
envejecer no queremos envejecer nadie
quiere cumplir 30 años oyendo los pase
hace tiempo y creanme en los 50 no son
los nuevos 20 pero lo tienen
y esto es un paréntesis
pero entonces cuando uno dice no quiero
envejecer ya estamos metidos en eso y la
otra dice eliminar el sufrimiento y la
enfermedad dijo lea y empieza a ver
cuestiones complicadas porque yo no
apoyo el sufrimiento per se pero el
sufrimiento es parte de la vida humana
los niños sufren al sufrimiento de un
niño no me malentiendan conocía alguna
vez un niño que la pasaba muy mal en
navidad
muy raro porque los niños están como
hyper ya saben en navidad esperando que
llegue santaclós en cualquier momento y
este niño la pasaba muy mal y un día
pregunté y dije que pasa y me dijo mira
termino esto es fácil
los papás te dicen que santa claus lo ve
todo y lo sabe todo
saben cómo me importe y no me va a tocar
nada este año
tú no les puedes decir al niño hoy
hinojo no saben nada no voy a dar la
respuesta porque a lo mejor aquí alguien
cree en santa claus
pero pero la realidad es que
pues no saben todo y todos los años le
llegaban regalos oigan pero la angustia
que ese niño vivía en inevitable
entonces el sufrimiento es parte de la
vida cuando amas por ejemplo la apuesta
hay esta si yo te amo y la pasta es mal
pierdes el trabajo te enfermas
evidentemente yo sufro es el costo del
amor no porque quien te ame te haga
sufrir eso no es verdad pero si por qué
querer al otro y arriesgarte por el otro
cuesta y cuesta en sufrimiento entonces
el sufrimiento es parte de la vida el
sufrimiento nos hace crecer nos hace
mejorar nos hace madurar
pero la propuesta dice
no debemos sufrir y entonces la gente
quiere tequila pastillas para no sufrir
y lo dejo ahí porque además si pensamos
que no voy a hablar de eso y no me toca
en respuestas como la autocracia todo el
argumento es por el sufrimiento para que
vean que metidos estamos en esta
propuesta después dice evitar la
condición mortal o gianni la enfermedad
a ver naturalmente queremos luchar por
nuestra vida es lo normal en los
vivientes nos gusta vivir pero una cosa
es luchar por nuestra vida curarnos y
otra cosa es no querer morir si vamos a
la literatura por ejemplo tenemos
ejemplos muy duros de los que no mueren
si pensamos en dorian gray el que vive
para siempre y el cuadro se va haciendo
viejo o en drácula que es una historia
que a mí personalmente me encanta
drácula que es oigan el que por amor
decide hacer un pacto con el [ __ ] para
no morir nunca oigan y el tipo sufre lo
indecible enema sale en la noche la cosa
es muy compleja yo yo voy a que pondría
a algunas cuestiones y seguiría adelante
qué pasaría si en vez de vivir 70 80
años
viviéramos 500 son 1000 años
qué necesidad de estudiar una carrera
tienes 500 años para que lo haces
ahorita qué necesidad oigan de echar
novio hoy tengo 500 años pero hoy ya se
vuelve muy complejo es que todos los
paradigmas cambian
cuáles son las áreas de trabajo fuertes
del transhumanismo esta es la super
longevidad esta parte de ser ser
eternamente jóvenes
a ver que hemos conseguido una parte si
ven películas de pedro infante por
ejemplo oigan pedro infante tenía 24
años y se parecía un señor y ya saben
ven a dolores del río yo sé a este elsa
aguirre que me van a saber quiénes son
google
oigan y era una señora casadera señorita
perdón y tenía 18 años
hoy en hoy en día alguien de 18 años es
un pool super baby
yo conozco gente de 30 que nada más
juega xbox y que vive con sus papás hoy
a mi papá a los 30 ya tenía dos hijos
fíjense cómo cómo hemos cambiado pero
pero no solo es mejorar nuestra
condición de vida es ser jóvenes por
siempre y eso me parece complicado
la segunda habla de la super
inteligencia que a ver estando en una
universidad me parece que es el core de
la presentación porque porque sería a
tener mayores posibilidades de aprender
cosas de potencializar nuestra parte
cognitiva que a ver a ver no me
malentiendan naturalmente podemos hacer
lo que quiere decir que si estrellita se
pone a estudiar todos los días cálculo
dos horas incluyendo sábados y domingos
y días festivos
hoy andén en un año
es una fregona en cálculo es la mejor y
lo que saben no se le va olvidar pero
qué problema tiene estrellita no se
quiere sentar a estudiar dos horas
diarias
quiere una pastillita que leas cuatro
horas antes del examen y lo sepas oigan
esto me parece complicado y entre la
super inteligencia habla de esto de
desarrollar medicamentos de desarrollar
gadgets nanotecnología para que para
potenciar nuestra parte cognitiva y la
otra parte de la superinteligente habla
de la inteligencia artificial de que
están hablando sobre todo hay un
empresario en california raymond
kurzweil que habla de que quiere que los
los sistemas se auto determinen oigan
las películas 2001 odisea del espacio él
y en todas estas futuristas que hablan
de las computadoras nos dominan es lo
que estos puentes se están proponiendo
qué pasaría con un sistema y estoy
jugando con la información qué pasaría
con un sistema que detectará todo lo
dañino y lo destruyera a poco creen que
nos salvaríamos
oigan acabamos con los ecosistemas
acabamos con animales nos hacemos daños
unos a otros
esto sería complicado y por último la
parte del super bienestar
este es david beers el que está muy
metido en esto también es un inglés como
que los ingleses lo traen otra vez
y este hombre dice oigan es que si lo
que nos gusta es el placer si lo que
disfrutamos es el placer porque no tener
placer todo el tiempo
o ya se puede oír muy atractivo a mí me
parece complicado porque además david
pearce plantea un placer
sobrehumano o más allá del talento
humano de la posición humana lo que más
está en este momento lo que más estamos
trabajando es el enhancement que es el
enganche el potenciamiento el potencial
nos cognitivamente el potenciar nos
físicamente
si se acuerdan de este hombre deportista
lance amstrong lanzan son ganó ocho
veces la tour de france
pero estaba dopado y tenía ciertas
transfusiones lo perdió todo
perdió patrocinadores perdió todo y
estos pensadores dicen por si lo que
queremos ver es gente rápida pues sale
las drogas que necesiten y que corran
más rápido ya este es bien fuerte
a ver si lo que nos gusta es ver a usain
bolt correr los 100 metros planos
en 6 en 40 segundos en touch of low que
lo corre en 10
y entonces aquí vienen muchas preguntas
y yo creo que yo me dedicaré a hacer
preguntas
o ya ni qué va a pasar con los que no
tengan con qué qué va a pasar con el
talento natural qué va a pasar con él
con la disciplina al trabajo y entonces
él neurogenes mente empieza a hablar ya
no sólo de la parte del pont
potenciamiento cognitivo dicen oye
porque no modificamos los estados de
ánimo de las personas
y la afectividad te doy una serie de
medicamentos para que me acepte si me
quieras
oigan hay un experimento que se hizo con
parejas que tenían problemas se les daba
de oxitocina para que para que no se
separen
yo pregunto insisto me voy a dedicar a
hacer preguntas no sería más importante
enseñar a las personas a crecer en el
amor
y a trabajar en el amor más que a darte
oxitocina y vasopresina para que quieras
estar con otro y por último que es la
parte más más compleja el potenciamiento
moral
julian suaves a burlesque y el
australiano dice
siempre nos es más fácil hacerle el bien
a las personas que conocemos desarrollo
desarrollamos medicamentos donde puedas
ver en el otro una cara familiar para
que para no hacer daño mi pregunta sería
y dónde queda la libertad y dónde está
lo que nosotros somos oigan y el trabajo
arduo y la disciplina es verdad que yo
puedo obtener un cuerpazo a ver yo no
tengo 52 años pero pero tengo lo mío no
me malentiendan pero pero si voy todos
los días al gimnasio como lo que debo de
comer ya sea es poca grasa mucho apio
estas cosas
oigan yo les apuesto que después de un
año mi cuerpo va a ser otro se los juro
pero eso requiere trabajo y haber el
trabajo no está en el resultado es el
proceso lo que nos hace humanos es que
disfrutamos el proceso después dice y la
disciplina no cabe duda que la
disciplina nos enseña muchas cosas de
los demás y de nosotros mismos o jan y
tenemos que regresar a las virtudes
carlos llano cifuentes un un filósofo
maravilloso que que fue el que es el que
desarrolló la idea del ipade en méxico
decía back to basics regresemos a nuevas
bases oigan volvamos a leer en textos en
libros volvamos a escribir apuntes
volvamos a tomar cafés con nuestros
amigos no puede ser todo por mensaje
volvamos a reírnos a carcajadas sin
alcohol sólo por reírte
que está en frente oigan tenemos mucho
que hacer
regresemos a lo básico muchas gracias
[Aplausos]